let me be real
if you want my honest opinion about what
you guys are saying exactly what we want
i would say that we're speaking a lot
about
scenarios
examples of toxic femininity but there's
no solution and i think speaking about a
problem without a solution is an issue
because we're highlighting the problems
but we're not coming to solutions of
them so you have a bag of things to
highlight however
we haven't been given
we have we haven't been given the
questions to solve them problems
so i think a lot of the traits that you
were talking about
toxic femininity
i can't relate to them because i'm not
that because i've changed my mindset so
a lot of these issues that we're dealing
with as women is a mindset problem and
one thing that i was listening to the
podcast yesterday and meditating on my
way here today was that
us as girls have been and men too but
let me speak on the women us as girls
have been indoctrinated from a young age
through magazines from early
to compare each other to other women to
show signs of
lying manipulation towards men
and these things have been ingrained
from young young to the point where you
don't even remember when these were
first put into your mind from time here
all of us probably the girls here
probably from age what 19 over to about
25
from young in tv shows cartoons disney
channels we've been shown how to move as
a woman
and the thing is right the world will
tell you how to move because they want
us to be against one another they want a
woman and a man to stand as opposition
when we're not we should be together so
when we're speaking on these things
about toxic femininity i don't know what
i call it's good to highlight but i
think there's a lot of places that
highlight it
um
but but let's solve it
how so wait so what are you trying to
say
how
cool
you got a lot to say we have to speak on
first of all mindset
so a lot of the issues that we're facing
was manipulation and lying
right so you need to fix your mindset
and not be a liar and for everything you
say to a man to be truthful and that's
one way you will what if lying gets you
what you want back of your problems
that's another issue that's manipulation
if you're lying to get what you want
you're manipulating people and you know
you're doing it because you're lying
about it and you are in your own mind so
you know what you're saying
so you're lying to yourself and you're
lying to others to your own gain so
manipulation and lying are the top two
and the third one i say which you kept
bringing up was jealousy between other
women
and this is what i was saying earlier is
that we've been taught to be jealous of
other women so until you have to tap
into self and realize listen
whatever i don't watch no faces what
other women do is on them but me i'm
gonna be true to me that's when you
change and that's when you see a group
of women changing and within your
friendship groups you can be the change
right so you can speak on things that
use that gossiping yeah me and my
friendship group have been speaking
recently a lot about gossip and
highlighting when we're we're gossiping
to one another about other women you
understand and we've been ingraining
that within our conversations as listen
guys we're gossiping let's finish this
one here switch to the next topic
because you'll be surprised there's
women out here that can see what the
world is pushing they can see all this
toxic femininity and we can see the
toxic masculinity but
again tap into self yeah and follow god
yeah and one thing i can bring on to so
other people can speak right we'll go
back to the fear and i'll share in my
mind earlier about there's two
definitions of fear so when you say to
fear a man i agree but in what way
because the fear of god which is to be
an awe
majesty god is god bowing down at the
feet of your creator that's fear right
and no man can make you feel like that
that's a different fear so when you're
bringing out the fear of man it's not
the same because men are fallen and we
are not gods yeah so then there's also
another fear which is
um i read it earlier and it was it was
it was a negative sense of fear so it's
the fear of being in trouble it's the
fear of
all the you search up online for
yourselves guys you'll see what fear
means and then you type in fear in a
biblical setting and it's too different
so there's the or of god and there's the
fear of man and the fear of man is that
punishment you know i'm saying uh you
know when you do something wrong there's
gonna be
repercussions repercussions yeah so so
in what way should i fear a man because
how can i be in awe of a man because
that makes the man my idol and i'm told
to not bow down to no other idols and
then it's like let me stop you right
here stop me please would you say you
are in right now you are in your
feminine energy or your masculine one
right now yeah feminine is your
masculine one i'm in me baby
that is
i mean hang on one second one second one
second one second
um
[Music]
you're saying a lot of things right
and you're on your and you're asking
women essentially right
to
not be women this guy was cheeky women
cheeky no no no woman not to be a woman
no i i'll tell you how you're asking a
lot to women how because women see other
women as competition
they do women have always seen other
women as competition because women are
competing for men
right and so if women are competing for
men when you say oh women shouldn't be
jealous they shouldn't be gossiping part
and parcel right of women competing for
other women is them trying to tear other
women down so they can get to that man
yes it is no because you're saying
you as a woman know that there are women
out there as we spoke about earlier on
today
that they're competing for a certain
type of men right
in competition yeah people try and
uh sabotage their competition people try
and tear down their competition people
try and diminish their competition right
that is part and parcel of the
quote-unquote game what you are asking
women to do is to not now be women and
also ask them to be in their more
masculine energy
so then if women are in their more
masculine energy they no longer compete
for the men that they want and they
start i mean you might as well just let
women be of women then cool let me speak
now
so
when you say competition and all these
things is coming across very
like animalistic that you're comparing
human existence to an animal's existence
in animal existence
for some i don't believe that though so
so for in an animalistic experience
right you are competing for males and
males are competing for females same way
or in a different in a different way but
same same example right
but but i believe that we're deeper than
animals and i believe i believe in god
and i believe i have a spirit and i
believe i have a plan so when it comes
to competing why am i competing for
something that i believe god has for me
i don't need to compete what is for me
will be for me so that madness is the
jealousy
that minus is the lion and that minus is
the manipulation and it also but hang on
but what it also does is make you live
in delusion
no because
because
because when you say oh if it's for me
it's for me do you know how many women
are single out here right now when it
comes to competing for men that just say
you know what i'm not going to compete
what is for me is for me are they dead
yet hang on hang on
wait wait do you know we do not have a
choice wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait do you know how many athletes if an
athlete just said oh you know what the
competition if it's for me is for me
i'll win no you get to work and you
compete and you go to win that's what
you do when you want to win you don't
just say oh well if it comes it comes uh
manchester city just won the premier
league the other day right they didn't
just say well you know what if it comes
it comes no there was a cult there they
were competing they had strategies they
knew exactly what they had to do to get
that cup right they knew exactly
it wasn't oh well if it's for us it's
for us guys no that whole that that's
delusion so when it comes to um when it
comes to relationships and when it comes
to uh men male and female it's actually
a competition
which is why
people dress differently which is why
people think which is why people are
makeup which is why people put on people
spruce themselves up to attract a mate
yeah that's just what we do so all of
this okay i get you you're a spiritual
person you like god all of this kind of
stuff is getting that's fine like that's
actually fine but what that's but you
know what there's a lot of single
christian women out there too do you
know what i'm saying and there's a lot
of happily married ones right of course
there are about 70 percent of the church
has single women there's 70 of the
churches a single christian women
looking for a man
so sorry i see what's going on here
obviously
beth has come here
on her boss lady are we out you know i
was like yeah you can on a bus ladies
[ __ ] unfortunately that's just what we
got here in it
no no fortunately for yourself that's
what you are and we can all clap for
that today
in fact we should and i will
but
unfortunately though the world that we
live in generally the majorities that
we're talking about are not of that and
you're in your boss lady in your own
right so we're talking about the general
consensus of women that are not reaching
on the things and then the generals on
are in the in the the the numbers that
we're talking about here and the
percentages that we're talking about
here because you know it
is you do that but majority of women
they they know that in a competition
beth i'll be honest with you that's this
you're talking facts i hear that but but
ain't they real well
but mostly but most people don't know
hear me hear me out most girls know that
in the game and they want to win
you understand i can't lie
i'll be real with you
the most people most people that have
that kind of that that think that kind
of way well like my way
the kind of way that you that you have
as well kind of have as well be real of
you and i don't want to offend you in a
kind of way
they're still single okay and
they'll they will they will get older
and older and older and when you get
older and older you you lose um what's
the word sexual values
and you realize you're in a game and
then and then you realize late on you're
losing this i hate
but i don't lose
that's
what i'm talking about guys
this is what i'm talking about like
delusional behavior because the thing is
i'm not saying that what you're saying
doesn't make sense that's not what i'm
saying i'm saying when you look at the
when you look at the wider the wider
world in which you live in yeah it's not
the way beth sees it right so hang on
hang on so the way beth sees it is the
way beth sees it and i get beth see beth
is her own individual and she moves by
her own rules and she does her own thing
i totally get that but when you step out
into the real world it ain't like that
right what it is is a competition so
women like like like i said women like
you they stay single for a long time and
then they realize oh you know what i'm
in a competition
actually and it's too late because the
competition that while i was saying oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna manifest it or i'm
just gonna be me and no there's a
competition going on out here